würdest du mir glauben wenn ich dir sage
dass du in wenigen Sekunden aus 100 €
3800 machen kannst also 3800 Bad und
nicht Euro und dafür musst du nur an den
Geldautomaten in Bangkok Thailand gehen
genau das was wir gemacht haben um zu
schauen wie weit man in 24 Stunden mit
100 € in der Mega Metropole Bangkok
Thailand kommt und so viel sei schon mal
gesagt man kommt ziemlich weit und die
Stadt ist völlig verrückt also viel Spaß
mit 100 € in
bankkok ist schon wieder soweit es geht
schon wieder los wir brauchen Bares und
zwar nicht gerade wenig 100 € sind
3564 Bad an dem Tag wo wir das heute
drehen und ich denke damit sollten wir
ewig weit kommen also wirklich ewig
weit so sieht es aus Tausender Scheine
Hunderter scheine die blauen sind die
puuffis der Taxifahrer hinter der Kamera
wint oder tuktuck Fahrer wint mir gerade
schon zu weil er die Kohle gesehen hat
wir gehen jetzt in den Markt Essen
Trinken gucken nach Souvenirs riesen
Markt Wochenendmarkt auf dem ich schon
mal war mega geil dann schauen wir mal
was der lach so bringt ne haben uns
Unterstützung geholt genauso in Vietnam
haben wir einen deutschen gefunden der
uns ein bisschen durch Bangkok führt ist
seit vier Wochen hier und mit dem werden
wir den Tag bestreiten sehr cool und
direkt zum Frühstück musste ich einen
großen Punkt meiner Thailand Checkliste
abhaken und ich denke jeder wird mir
zustimmen ein absoluter must try und
mein favorite food in Thailand sticky
rice mit Mang one time with sticky rice
okay thank
you
60 Bad quasi eine komplette Mango und
sticky rice da drunter ist ziemlich süß
mit kokosmussmilch oben drauf aber
hammergeil wirklich hammergeil seit vier
Jahren nicht mehr gegessen hab die ganze
Reise schon darauf gewartet nach Bangkok
zu kommen nach Thailand zu kommen
endlich wieder sticky rice mit Mango zu
essen hammergeil und wenn man schon mal
auf einem Markt in Thailand ist kann man
es sich natürlich nicht nehmen lassen
all die anderen tollen Dinge auch noch
zu probieren und genau das haben wir
getan Passion food Smoothie thank you
thank you Hauptgericht Nudeln mit
Schwein 60 Bad wier der Smoothie war 60
Bad sticky rice 60 Bad alles 60 Bad
K watermelon kauf mir einfach noch
Früchte es ist es ist wie im
Schlaraffenland also 50 B zweiter
Smoothie dieses Mal Mango und 40 Bad für
die frische Wassermelone Nachtisch
nachdem ich gerade schon ein vortisch
hatte und dann ein Hauptgang und jetzt
wieder eine nach und dreimal dürft ihr
raten wer seine Sonnenbrille vergessen
hat richtig obwohl mir klar war dass wir
nach Bangkok Thailand fliegen aber
glücklicherweise gibt es auf
thailändischen Märkten auch dafür
ziemlich günstige Abhilfe thank you
bisschen über 1 € für diese Sonnenbrille
und damit müsst ihr mich jetzt zum einen
über das gesamte Video so ertragen zum
anderen kann ich aber auch vernünftig
Richtung Kamera
gucken gerade auf solchen Märkten ist es
super verführerisch mehr zu kaufen als
man eigentlich möchte solange es um
sticky rise und Sonnenbrillen geht ist
das auch noch okay passiert das beim
großen ist die Urlaubskasse schneller
leer als man gucken kann und um auf
Reisen und zu Hause mein Geld immer im
Überblick zu behalten gibt es finanzguru
den Partner des heutigen Videos
finanzguru ist dein digitaler
finanzassistent der alle deine ein und
Ausgaben von verschiedenen konent trckt
dabei ist es völlig egal ob Girokonto
Sparkonto Aktiendepot oder sogar Paypal
und das Beste das Tool ist komplett
kostenlos ihr seht also genau was
reinkommt und viel wichtiger ihr seht
alles was rausgeht weißt du z.B wie viel
Streaming Abos du hast oder welche
fixzahlung überhaupt jeden Monat
anstehen finanzguru checkt genau das
über regelmäßige Kontobewegung und gibt
euch eine Möglichkeit all diese Verträge
direkt in der App rechtss sicher zu
kündigen die App lernt also anhand von
eurem Einnahmen und Ausgabenverhalten
euch einen zuverlässigen Überblick über
eure Finanzen und Sparpotenziale zu
geben vielleicht zeigt euer Konto 1000 €
an finanzguro weiß aber dass in den
nächsten Tagen noch Miete GZ und
Handyvertrag gezahlt werden müssen
weswegen euch real eigentlich nur 450 €
bleibt das ist super wichtig damit ihr
nicht über euren Verhältnissen lebt und
eine wirklich gute Übersicht über eure
Finanzen habt für mich ist finanzgeru
das number one Tool um alle Konten auf
einen Blick zu haben und mit einem
klaren Kopf finanzmäßig ins neue Jahr
starten zu können und mit dem Code Dave
gibt es finanzbüro Plus für 3 Monate
komplett kostenlos damit schaltet ihr
noch mal unendlich viele Extras frei wie
z.B smarte budgetvorschläge unendlich
viele Analysen und die Möglichkeit
zukünftige Buchung zuen also ladet euch
jetzt die App herunter registriert euch
fügt eure Konten hinzu und tragt den
Code da ein um dauerhaft wirklich guten
Überblick über eure Finanzen zu behalten
vielen Dank an finanzguro fürs möglich
machen dieses Videos und euch viel Spaß
weiter mit dem Video nach dieser
Reizüberflutung und S viel kann ich
schon mal versprechen es war nicht die
letzte ging es für uns zurück ins Hotel
und das nicht mit dem Taxi das wäre ja
zu einfach und wir haben ja eine
tugiliste abzuhaken deswegen mit dem
tukt
Hammer es ist dieses eine bestimmte
Gefühl das mir schwer fällt zu
beschreiben aber für mich ist Thailand
ist Urlaub in Südostasien einfach
wirklich peakurlaub unheimlich viele
Möglichkeiten das alles zu einem super
günstigen Preis wenn man will super
schöne ruhige Landschaften auf einer
kleinen Insel wie Coto und super Chao
isch mega viel los in Bangkok irgendwie
ist diese Mischung aus beidem für mich
einfach der absolute Traum schlafen tun
wir im ramada Plaza super modernes vier
Stern Hotel wie das ins Budget passen
kann erkläre ich euch gleich auf der
sukumit Road leider etwas außerhalb aber
suked Road eine der Hauptstraßen auf der
wir uns auch schon Wohnungen in einem
der letzten Videos angeschaut haben also
super easy mega schnell in die Stadt zu
kommen hallo und herzlich willkommen zum
besten Zimmer das wir jemals in 100 € in
hatten und zwar 100 € in Bangkok tretet
ein ich würde schätzen ungefähr 25 26
mad im Eingangsbereich befindet sich
draußen vor dem Badezimmer das
Waschbecken ziemlich groß ziemlich
schick insgesamt ist das Hotel super neu
also ich glaube weniger als ein Jahr
hier hat man Stauraum eine Mikrowelle zu
meiner Rechten geht es ins Bad
bodentiefe Dusche super schick alles
wunderbar gefällt mir sehr gut und weil
es so neu ist ist auch alles frisch ich
habe öfter mal in Südostasien die
Erfahrung gemacht dass gerade in der
Dusche dann so etwas na ja die
Qualitätsstandards nicht ganz mit den
deutschen konform sind hier ist es
allerdings so alles neu alles fresh mega
nice und hier aus dem Flur und dem
Badezimmer geht es dann ins wirklich
wirklich große und geräumige Zimmer wir
haben mega viel Platz also hier ist
Platz hier hier wir haben einen großen
Fernseher alles neu unser Kleiderschrank
wir haben eine Sitzecke und das alles
jetzt hört mir genau zu für 27 € pro
Person pro Nacht sechster Stock toop wir
starten mit dem Gin wie immer das von
uns nicht benutzt aber wirklich sehr
schick überall Spiegel man merkt dass es
super neu ist mega geil schick gemacht
mit so bunten Fenstern die ziehen sich
draußen am Pool auf Weiter und den
schauen
[Musik]
jetzt neben dem eigentlichen Pool haben
wir so eine pool area an der man chillen
kann da ist eine Bar sind
Sitzmöglichkeiten und wir haben einfach
unheimlich gute Aussicht also große
Gebäude um uns rum jetzt beim
Sonnenuntergang richtig geil deswegen
werden wir den Pool ein Besuch
Abstanden mir fehlt so ein bisschen die
Worte hier auf dieser Seite der Welt in
dieser Region ist das Geld einfach
deutlich weniger wert und das merkt man
100 € sind hier ein Budget das man an
einem Tag nicht leer bekommen na ja
außer man legt drauf an und kauft sich
Karten für ein echten Kampf wenn wir
schon mal da sind müssen wir auch das
[Musik]
machen ist nichts anderes als thaiiboxen
und nichts anderes als Thaiboxen ist
eigentlich der völlig falsche ausduck
denn es ist viel mehr als das es ist
viel mehr als ein Sport es ist
Nationalsport und fast Nationalgefühl
würde ich sagen neben MMA gilt mu Thai
als einer der härtesten Kampfsportarten
im Prinzip ist alles erlaubt außer
Schläge auf den Hinterkopf Bisse und so
weiter und es geht wirklich hart zur
Sachen am Ende war der mu Kampf eines
meiner absoluten Highlights der gesamten
Asienreise also von allen Sachen die wir
von Japan über Vietnam bis nach Thailand
gemacht haben wirklich was ganz
besonderes großes Stadion inmitten der
einheimischen man spürt die Emotionen
und hat einfach eine gute Zeit und für
den Preis vollkommen okay aber auch die
Zeit im Stadion hat uns Hunger gemacht
bevor wir uns darum kümmern erstmal noch
zu einem Tipp wir fahren nach Chinatown
und das mit dem
Taxi China Town market jetzt wurde uns
empfohlen von dem einheimischen weil der
gesagt hat das ist der Mark wo auch noch
einheimische hingehen wo es nicht
komplett nur auf Touris ausgelegt ist
sieht ziemlich cool aus hier Durian die
Stinkfrucht habe ich schon diverseste
Male gegessen aber ist jetzt für heute
Abend nichts gibt's alles eingepackt
frisch zubereitet nicht zubereitet echt
echt krass willkommen auf der Chaos
sunroad es ist wie eine gesunde Mischung
aus ballerann Lorette ma und Reperbahn
das hört sich schon verrückt an und
genauso ist es auch die Chaos sunroad in
Thailand Bangkok muss man gesehen haben
klar es spiegelt nicht das klassische
Thailand wieder ist eher darauf aus
ausgelegt den Backpackern und Reisenden
für ein oder maximal zwei Abende eine
möglichst gute Zeit zu machen und
möglichst viel Geld aus der Tasche zu
ziehen und genau dort in mitten von
gerösteten Skorpionen Neonlichtern und
zu lauten Musikboxen werden wir zu
Abendessen gehen Standard Partei das ist
super einfaches Gericht ich meine der
Großteil von euch wird's kennen 60 Bad
selbst hier auf der Straße also weniger
als 2 € ist kann ich kann die 100 € hier
nicht
ausgeben und es schmeckt lich gut nach
dem Essen sind wir Richtung Hotel und
komplett platt fertig und zufrieden ins
Bett gefallen auch wenn Bangkok
natürlich noch eine Menge Nightlife
mäßig für uns bereit gehalten hät aber
wir kommen zum wie sehr lohnt sich eine
Reise Ranking bei Bangkok muss ich sagen
ist es für mich was ganz besonderes
Anreise Bangkok ist absolut kein
Geheimtipp mehr jeder der nach dem Abi
nicht nach Australien reist kommt
wahrscheinlich an Südostasien nicht
vorbei und damit auch nicht an Bangkok
deswegen Flüge ab 400 € wahrscheinlich
eher so 500 das ist eine solide 3 von F
ist ja auch eine lange Strecke location
Bangkok ist schon ziemlich krass ich
betrachte es aber viel mehr als eine
Bewertung für Thailand denn Thailand
besticht durch seine Kontraste man hat
die mega Metropole Bangkok in der alles
super schnell LEBIG modern und irgendwie
auch ein bisschen abgefuckt ist auf der
anderen Seite unberührte Natur auf
irgendwelchen einsamen Inseln
locationmäßig kommt da wirklich wenig
dran ich würde eine fünf von fünf geben
und genauso geht es beim funftor weiter
Bangkok ist Bangkok nicht ohne grundwohl
einer der hangoverteile storymäßig um
Bangkok drum herum gebaut ansonsten auf
den Inseln kannst du unheimlich viel
erleben Thailand hat einiges zu bieten
und ich würde fast sagen da kommt sehr
wenig dran bzw kommt gar nichts dran von
den Ländern die ich bisher erlebt habe
fün von F beim Wohlfühlfaktor sieht es
etwas anders aus aber lasst mich
erklären in den ersten Tagen in denen
man nach Thailand kommt in denen man als
Tourist in Südostasien unterwegs ist
muss man sich wahrscheinlich erstmal ein
bisschen dran gewöhnen mittlerweile
fühle ich mich komplett wohl
wohlfülfaktor würde ich fast sagen fünf
von fünf aber weil so am Anfang so ein
bisschen komisches Gefühl mit schwingt
gebe ich eine vier von fünf das alles
legt sich über die die Zeit alle Leute
sind super nett nie eine wirklich
sketchy Situation erlebt natürlich muss
man aufpassen nicht hier und da gerippt
zu werden aber so ist das vier von fünf
noch mal hinfaktor letzte Kategorie was
soll ich sagen ich würde sofort noch mal
hin ich würde jedem empfehlen mal nach
Thailand zu fliegen ganz klare fünf von
fünf und das ist auch das was ich von
Kumpels gehört habe die unabhängig von
mir auch schon mal da waren wie z.B
crispy Rob einmal dahine gefahren sich
verliebt man würde immer wieder hin ganz
klare Nummer und damit rank Thailand bzw
Bangkok ganz klar auf Platz 1 der 100 €
inserie es gibt noch unheimlich viel zu
entdecken wenn ihr Ideen habt schreibt
es in die Kommentare vergesst nicht den
Kanal zu abonnieren das war's mit dieser
Folge lasst den Video ein Like da wir
sehen uns nächste Woche wieder macht's
gut
[Musik]
ciao